yes I do think that I Speaker of the
House I have done everything in my power
to get our troops out of Iraq on many
occasions more than five we have sent
legislation to the Senate with either a
time certain or honoring their request a
goal for when our troops should come
home most recently in this appropriation
season for the supplemental when we said
that the redeployment should begin 30
days after enactment of the law the
that's all that we can do in the House
of Representatives because of the
60-vote requirement in the Senate we
have not been able to get legislation to
the President's desk because the 60
votes requires Republican cooperation
and so I believe that as soon as we have
a new president will have better
opportunity on the other hand not not
just strictly speaking about the
withdrawal of troops which is essential
to our national security and to the
stability of the region we have also in
the house made oversight congressional
oversight a priority to hold this
administration accountable to not let
stand statements that they make about
what is happening in Iraq to give the
American people the ground truth of what
is happening on the ground in Iraq and
trying to impress upon the president of
the fact that the American people have
left him long ago on this war we'd been
there two years longer than we were in
World War two it's time to bring wall
over due time for us to bring our troops
home safely honorably responsibly and
soon which it never had been there in
the first place
you